YOU THANK YOU. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING MASKS ARE
REQUIRED AT ALL TIMES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
NEAR THE NORTH STEPS AND BY
PHONE. THE NUMBER FOR THE PHONE
TESTIMONY IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO THIS
NUMBER IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND ALSO
APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED. ONCE
THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY. SECRETARY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO. CALL THE ROLL. RIVAS
HERE RIVAS HERE FLORA FLORA
HERE CHAU FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
HERE GARCIA GARCIA HERE MATHIS
YOUR MATHIS HERE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI SAY ARTHUR HERE
SARATOGA HERE STONE STONE HERE
WOOD YOU'RE- RIGHT HERE. THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONLY FOUR BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY THREE OF WHICH
ARE PROPOSED CONSENT S. B. TWO
SEVENTY TWO LAYERED S. B. THREE
FOUR SEVEN CABALLERO SB SEVEN
ZERO NINE DOLLY. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. RIVAS I RIVAS
AYE FLORA FLORA HI CHAU
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI GARCIA
GARCIA HI MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MARTUCCI SAY ARTE HI
THERE TO ALL RIGHT STONE. STONE
HI WOULD I WOULD I. EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO. AB WE HAVE ONE
BILL- S. B. EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BOB DOLE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO COME UP AND PRESENT. EVERY
MORNING I'M SURE THAT THERE'S A
PATTERN HERE TO PRESENT. FOR
PRESENTATION. IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT. ABOUT IS A OFFICE ON BILL
AND WHATNOT- ROCK RIGHT CAN YOU
SKEWS ME I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT MY. IS WE- THE SOUND LIKE
AT LEAST MIKE ON. YEAH HOLD ON.
YEAH YOU'RE MY CONSENT ON ITS
NOT A GOOD MORNING RIGHT NOW.
IS THERE. BOTH SIDES ON THE
OTHER SIDE. OKAY. ONE ON. YOUR.
OKAY TWENTY SEVENTEEN YES
CONTINUE THANK YOU OKAY- SO
IT'S DONE SO THIS BILL STEMMED
OUT OF HEARING IN MY DISTRICT-
AND ADDRESSES AN ISSUE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS MY
DISTRICT ARE WHAT THAT SAID S.
B. EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES
ENHANCED REPORTED RELATIVE TO
HAZARDOUS LONG TERM IDOL AN
ORPHAN WELLS TODAY THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED SEVEN
THOUSAND ACTIVE ARE AT IDLE OIL
AND GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT AND PRODUCTION
OCCURS IN THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL
VALLEY. IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
THIS REGION A NUMBER OF LONG
TERM IDLE AND ABANDONED OIL
WELLS THAT ARE NOT PROPERLY TO
COME THE COMMISSION CONTRIBUTE
TO LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THOUGH THE
STATE HAS ENACTED LEGISLATION
TO ADDRESS AND PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR REMEDIATION OF LONG TERM
IDOL AN ORPHAN WELLS ALONG NOT
ENOUGH SEEMS TO BE GOING TO
WHERE WE HAVE. MOST OF THESE
WELLS. SB EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AROUND
OFTEN ALONG WITH MEDIATION
GIVES US A BETTER PICTURE OF
WHAT EQUITY AND WELL
REMEDIATION SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN PART TO
COMMITTEE REQUIRED CAL JAM-
TAKE. LOCATION REPORTED INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN CONSIDERING-
DEPRIVE THE PRIORITIZATION OF
WHILE REMEDIATION DISTRIBUTION
OF FUNDS ACT HERE. ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I HAVE
CLING TO LIVE A FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BISS BISS FEED
BINS FED BIZ FEB FIVE. HEY A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP ON THE PHONE LINE FOR A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND YOU WANT ONLINE TO OPEN AT
THIS TIME. FOUR OF OUR WITNESS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE
LINE IS OPEN OKAY. THANK YOU
ALL A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CLINT OLIVIER AND I'M THE
CEO OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BUSINESS FEDERATION I THINK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY FOUR AS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT WILL
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE THE
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING. ABORT
AND WELCOME THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PARTICULARLY KERN COUNTY IS THE
LEADING ENERGY SPACE FROM
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE BELIEVE IN
ALL OF THE ABOVE ENERGY
STRATEGY. A RECENT STUDY BY THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION FOUND THAT KERN
COUNTY IS TRULY LEADING BY
HAVING SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS TO PERMITTED WIND AND
SOLAR PROJECTS SUPPLYING 25% OF
CALIFORNIA'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
HAVING SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF BATTERY STORAGE
BEING BUILTQUOTES WHEN CAPITAL
OF THE WORLD WITH OVER FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED WIND TURBINES. AND
OF COURSE IS THE NUMBER SEVEN
OIL PRODUCING COUNTY IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH OF COURSE
IS WHAT WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT
THE DAY THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY IT'S CRITICAL TO THE
ECONOMY OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND IT'S ESSENTIAL TO ALL OF
OUR EVERYDAY LIVES. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTED IDLE OIL AND GAS
WELLS IN THE STATE MANY OF
WHICH ARE ACTIVELY MANAGED BY
RESPONSIBLE OPERATOR HOWEVER
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF WELLS
WITH THE OPERATOR IS INSOLVENT
OR HAS DESERTED THESE WEALTH
AND THE NEED TO BE PLUGGED AND
ABANDONED PROPERLY MOST OF THE
OIL AND GAS OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ACTIVELY
MANAGING AND ACCOUNTING FOR THE
IDYLLWILD THAT THEY OWN. HI
THROUGH EITHER AN IDOL WELL
MANAGEMENT PLAN OR PAYING
ANNUAL IDOL WILL BE AN IMPACT
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION ACTUALLY
HELPED FUND THE ON GOING
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING OF
THESE WELL. THIS BILL BY
SENATOR D'AMATO IS AN
ADDITIONAL STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE STATE'S NEED TO FURTHER
ADDRESS APARTMENT WELL BY
HAVING CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC
ENERGY MANAGEMENT DIVISION OR
CAL JAM IN ITS ANNUAL REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO IDENTIFY
THESE IDLE WELLS THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY BOARDMAN AND ALSO
REQUIRES CAL JAM TO IDENTIFY
THE LOCATION BY COUNTY. OF
THESE WELLS AND TWO IN OPERATE
THAT IN THE PRIOR. PROCESS
THANK YOU ALL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ON SENATOR D'AMATO'S S.
B. EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- I SEE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- REGISTERED TO-
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION UP SO I'D
LIKE TO OPEN THE PHONE LINES
TWO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. A
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES AND THIS IS FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL ONLY.
THANK YOU A MOMENT. AND IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE
ONLINE. THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
C. NINE I DON'T SEE ANY OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY LOCATION ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HE'S SEE NON- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO. WAIT A MOTION THIS
IS MISTER MATHIS SECOND BY A
DOCTOR WOULD. OF WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NAME.
THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON SB EIGHTY FOUR DO PASS
AND RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS HI HI.
FLORA LAURA HI CHAU FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HI GARCIA GARCIA HI
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MARTUCCI SAY ARTE HI THERE TO
ALL RIGHT STONE. STONE HI WOOD
WOOD I. VOTERS EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU VOTE IS A TERRIBLE LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THOSE THAT WANT TO ADD
ON. THANK YOU.
TWEET WE NEED
MCCARTY AND MURATSUCHI RIGHT.
AND CHAO- YEAH STARTED OUT OKAY
LET'S GO AHEAD AND YEAH OKAY SO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE
BILL RIGHT SB EIGHTY FOUR
MARTUCCI- TO GI. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI.
SO THREE NINE ZERO NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE YEAH SO I.
THE.
YEAH.
OKAY K. UP CAN OPEN-
ALLOW MR MCCARTY TO ADD ON. SB
EIGHTY FOUR CURRENT LOTUS NINE
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I'D MCCARTY.
THIRTY FIVE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CURRENT LOTUS NINE
ZERO SHARE VOTING AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. AND IS THERE A QUE
PRETENDE ZERO WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN.
WELL I'M SECRETARY OF
PLEASE. OPEN THE WORLD TO ADD
OKAY ON SB EIGHTY FOR THE
CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO ZERO
CHAIR VOTING AYE CHOW CHOW HI
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO ZERO
CHAIR VOTING HI CHAU. CHOW HI.
EVERYTHING SURE OF COURSE THANK
YOU THE MEETING ADJOURNED. THAT
WAS INTERESTING. I WAS WE WERE
WATCHING IT AWAY.